actualités sociales en France avec la
grève des éboueurs qui se poursuit à
Marseille aujourd'hui à l'accord partiel
a été signé à l'issue de la rencontre
entre syndicat et représentant de la
métropole hier mais tout ne sont pas
d'accord et certains poursuis donc le
mouvement contre l'augmentation du temps
de travail et les syndicats toujours
grévistes réclame maintenant une
rencontre avec le premier ministre Jean
Castex qui lui est déjà sur place depuis
hier car il doit faire un point sur le
plan Macron qui avait été annoncé il y a
3 mois on en parle tout de suite avec
notre invité Patrice IH secrétaire
général FO et boire à Marseille
[Musique]
Patricia bonjour
bienvenue dans la matinale de de rt
France ce matin on le disait il y a eu
des discussions hier avec la métropole
qu'en est-il ressorti et pourquoi le
mouvement se poursuit ce matin
et bien écouté comme vous le savez il
n'en n'est pas ressorti grand-chose
pourquoi le mouvement pour la petite
histoire en octobre dernier on nous
avait juré les grands dieux la
ministration que les 9 ans et demi pour
ça ne pouvait pas être dépassé que le
préfet mais ce n'est pas passé c'est
pour ça que pour répondre à Monsieur
Lorraine qui était sur une radio du
service public ce matin qui s'est donné
qu'on demande maintenant un tour
supérieure à 9 et demi c'est car époque
on nous a
assuré que 1h30 pour 100 pardon ne
pouvait pas être dépassé il se trouve
que lors de la réunion d'hier après-midi
en fin d'après-midi ce même monsieur
Morel propose de passer en force une
délibération hauteur de 15 %
tonton c'est très bien nous loto avec
satisfaction que le politique
prend ses responsabilités
mais ce que nous disons c'est pourquoi
s'arrêter du coup à 15 % pourquoi ne pas
aller jusqu'à la hauteur des vraies
revendications des agents qui leur
permettrait de réaliser
leur travail dans les meilleures
conditions de pénibilité possible et
c'est nous demande au nous à ce qu'on
passe des libérations à 35 %
profs pardon pour
propriétaire qui râle parce qu'il y a
des ordures dans les rues commerçante
on en est tout à fait conscient et à
nous en sommes désolés mais j'ai envie
de dire j'ai envie de renvoyer
la responsabilité sur l'administration
encore une fois ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui est l'effet d'une loi qui
date de 2019 nous sommes en 2021 tout le
monde savait qu'il y aurait cette
problématique
de temps de travail à régulariser avant
le 1er janvier 2022 dans nous avions
largement le temps d'ouvrir les
négociations et de travailler dans la
sérénité au lieu de sœur
d'administration as fait le choix de
décaler
ouvrir la discussion qu'à partir de
octobre dernier on peut se poser la
question d'ailleurs de demander si elle
l'a pas fait sciemment pour un petit peu
dialogue social et donc non
malheureusement c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas les voir c'est pas le syndicat
qui prend en otage de la population
c'est bien la démonstration et c'est
pour ça que nous saluer l'entrée dans la
boucle des politiques mais
malheureusement là encore il se rentrer
trop tard on repris le travail ce matin
les notamment le syndicat de la CGT du
coup est-ce que ça va pas avoir une
conséquence sur le mouvement qui risque
peut-être de s'essouffler
je ne pense pas réellement
[Musique]
dans quel secteur hier soir bon
elle qui a accepté l'accord aussi j'ai
pas trop vu de patrouille de te remonter
de le retourner sur sur le secteur tu
penses qu'on peut vous en dire c'est que
nous allons vraisemblablement convoquer
une assemblée générale extraordinaire
des éboueurs parce que c'est comme ça
que nous fonctionnons une prendre le
[Musique]
syndicat majoritaire
donc
le mouvement pour le moment donc vous
assurer que il est pas terminé
malheureusement comme quoi il est pas
terminé
je te signale quand même que c'est un
mouvement qui impactent l'ensemble des
éboueurs de France et pas que de
Marseille c'est dire que peut-être qu'il
y a quelque chose a changé dans 7 jours
j'ai entendu ce matin premier ministre
sur sur une radio du service public
des 15 % vous savez pas si ça rentre
dans le cadre de la loi
qui empêche d'aller
en visage
[Musique]